good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
today is Monday it's a beautiful new day
new week in New York City hey Claude how
you durn hey Jax I am starting this week
on a great foot I feel like my mental
health is in who gonna check me boo I'm
feeling so much lighter so much brighter
I got so much sleep over the weekend and
I just like really relaxed I did so many
puzzles I woke up extra early this
morning like did my laundry I'm feeling
like this might be like one of the most
productive weeks um in quarantine yet
because I actually have like a lot of
stuff a lot of the seeker projects that
I've been telling people about um one of
them is coming to light this week and I
haven't really been that secret about it
because like we literally quote my
comedy special but this week you will
get a release state you will get
pre-order options you will get the cover
art the name the trailer
I'm so excited like this is the
culmination of my life and then another
project that I'm working on I have a big
deadline coming up so this next like 2
or 3 weeks like I am busy and I'm just
planning on being the best version of
myself we'll see if my mental health
stays this like fire but if it does like
there's no stopping me Jackie like I'm
gonna take over the world when
quarantine is over bull say wow that is
so exciting
I - I'm having already a very productive
morning because I just dropped my new
preset pack I haven't dropped a piece at
preset pack since I think like November
um and this preset pack it's called the
pastel pack because if you've been
seeing my feet it's just been a lot more
like light and cotton candy-like
and this preset pack I've been working
on like since December and you can tell
because some of the photos that are the
cover photos for the pack are from
December so like I only ever want to
sell presets that I actually use and it
takes me a while to figure out which
ones that I've made are my favorites and
this pack it's just like it's a whole
new vibe I'm so excited
also I'm coming up on my Jackie O flow
one year anniversary and like we've come
so far in a year like we're the first
packs that I sold which were super
saturated and like so fun and I think we
were just kind of bucking everyone in
their orange photos on Instagram and now
this new pack it's so [ __ ] cleany and
you know I wanted to call it the plain e
pack that I do
think there are people who buy my
presets who don't know who I am and if I
called it the plain EPAct they would
just be like what is this so I had to
call it the pastel pack um if you're
like posting photos from home and you
just like need to punch them up a little
bit like this is the pack I really had
the cue in mind when I fine-tuned this
pack there's seven presets in the pack
for $30 total each preset is really
transformative there's one preset in
there though that is like the hallmark
of this collection and it might have
yeah oh I was gonna say home
no it's called cotton candy but that's
the name I came up for it in my phone
it's saved as new studio and that's
because it's the preset that I made for
the photos that we post from our studio
and I use it on now I use it on every
single photo not even the ones from the
studio but like the studio just inspired
this new vibe so like that is really my
number one preset right now and I think
it works for everything I actually got a
free pack and they're fabulous I'm like
gonna have a photo shoot in my underwear
later um stay tuned yeah like if you
just want to snap a mirror pick
something at home like low-key these
presets we'll just like fine-tune that
and it's a whole new vibe so I'm so
excited and they still work with the old
presets like it's still in the Jackie O
flow family but we made a left turn a
little bit and it's it's exciting love
making left turns also yesterday my
allergies just decided to come out in
full force I thought that I would escape
allergy season because we're in the
queue and I'm not really leaving the
house but I ran some errands yesterday
and when I got home like I got into bed
laughing I could not stop sneezing I had
to take two benadryl so I was out like a
light hey light hey so I slept about a
good 11 hours on the bee and I'm feeling
Gras like weird you know that plant a
circle is a hell of a drug it's a hell
of a drug it was really nice just to
fall asleep immediately like turn off
Ugly Betty
hit the hay there's nothing better than
falling asleep immediately and we've
spoken on this show many times about how
truly I'm traumatizing it is to have to
like lay awake at night and just like
think
and your husband's asleep and he's
snoring oh my god Bennett's been talking
in his sleep so much and he's always
talking about work and you know it kind
of makes me feel good because I'm like
if man was ever having an affair I'm
like I would know because he'd probably
confess in his sleep 100% but he's like
we got a pitch to Burger King and I'm
like excuse me are you talking to me and
it takes me a minute to realize that
he's sleep talking it's really scary to
like wake up to a voice in the middle of
the night that is really scary
yeah like yelling at you spooky stuff
speaking Burger King I'm so hungry but I
am back on my grind like now that we're
going into week 9 of quarantine I've
decided that it's the time to get snatch
alert and I'm back to Enderman fasting
and I'm just like trying to be the girl
that I used to be you know speaking of
Burger King I think I'm gonna what are
McDonald's today I think that you should
yeah it's I honestly I've only ordered
McDonald's once in the quarantine and it
was a great day it's kind of
inappropriate like that it's been so
infrequent yeah that is very
inappropriate I have to support my local
McDonald's you really do I would like
one day and the cue light went to a
McDonald's and picked up a fries and a
soda because I just felt like that's
what my soul needed and very much so was
what my soul needed I went into a
McDonald's when I was walking to you
know feel just kind of like led me there
and I swore to myself I was only gonna
get a soda and I walk in and the soda
machines are down oh my god yeah when we
went they weren't doing fountain soda
they were giving out bottles but you
know how I you know how I feel about
bottled soda like that's my favorite
kind of soda is the one in in the tall
thin model awful like irrational survive
for a fountain soda and the fact that I
walked all the way over there and there
wasn't even like machines open was
really upsetting oh wait I tell you on
my afternoon walk yesterday I had the
most active walk like that I've ever had
well I heard a little bit about it on
your Instagram stories but for people
who might be taking a break from
Instagram why don't you share with us
oh that's about to meet me I only maybe
I only walked like around the block and
first I ran into my friend David Cohen
and his whole family they were like on a
walk for Mother's Day and it was just
like so nice to see people in his
was so nice and I was just like wanting
to hug them I like we're not even that
close I just like was like craving love
you know we're craving a hug it's been a
while yeah and we like you know elbow
bumped which is like not what I needed
and then I was walking into my building
and I ran into this toaster and her
husband and she was so nice she was like
the toast is everything it was just like
everything I needed to hear and I was
like I haven't seen a toaster in the
wild I used to see a toaster in the wild
minimum once a day yeah I haven't seen
one in like almost three months so it
was just so good like she was so sweet
couldn't really see her face because she
was wearing a mask but I felt like she
was beautiful oh my god she's a
beautiful soul if she was a toaster in
the wild total wow that's that's really
really lovely I couldn't believe it she
was talking to me and I was like is this
woman gonna yell at me that I'm not
wearing my mask properly because that's
all that people do in the street now in
New York it's like they criticize one
another so at first I was like you know
what I'm not taking my ear pods out
because this woman's gonna yell at me
for something you know she was like
Claudia and I was like yeah she's like
I'm a toaster I'm like oh my god thank
God so it ended up being a really
pleasant social interaction Wow I'm so
so happy for you this was a nice weekend
very relaxing for me I feel like I'm not
even equipped to host this show today
because I am so unplugged from like
what's going on in the world because I'm
only watching Ugly Betty and sleeping
and eating you know yeah so in the world
of Ugly Betty like things are really
heating up like Daniel Meade was
extorted it was so crazy
Rebecca Romijn same house is in the
building oh my god I just gotta remain
stable how dare you that's so difficult
Jerry O'Connell who was a guest on this
show I know
Wow Wow mom I think part of the reason
that you feel like out of touch with the
world and I feel the same is because we
don't have our Facebook group oh maybe
oh my god but maybe that's why your
mental health feels fire though oh my
god you're right it's the one week
anniversary without the face of group
and I feel lighter than ever
lighter than ever it's directly it's all
directly correlated so true wow that's
really crazy
well um also I think it's that this
weekend like not that much happened in a
lot of suburbs but stuff happens so
we're gonna get into it
I feel like it could be time yeah okay
you guys without further ado et's time
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast Oh
and that's true Jackie but as the
weather heats up and the days get longer
article is here to make your dream patio
a reality with weather-resistant dining
sets loungers and sofas article
selection of outdoor furniture makes it
easy to create your patio oasis in time
for the summer season if you have a
patio and it's not the happiest place on
earth like you don't deserve your patio
like if I had a patio I would go to
article and I would get like dining
living like I would get everything
umbrellas couches like everything I
would make that outdoor space not only
during quarantine but outside of
quarantine I would make it the happiest
place on earth
so if you are in need of outdoor
furniture get to article because they
combine the curation of boutique
furniture stores with the comfort and
simplicity of shopping online their team
of designers focuses on beautifully
crafted pieces quality materials and
durable construction they are dedicated
to a modern aesthetic of mid-century
Scandinavian industrial and bohemian
designs they have fair prices where you
could save up to 30% over traditional
retail prices article is able to keep
their prices low by cutting out the
middleman selling directly to you
there's no showrooms and no salespeople
and no retail markups they have fast
affordable shipping available across the
USA and Canada and it's free on orders
of over nine hundred and ninety nine
dollars all the in stock items are
delivered in two weeks or less I can
attest to the fabulous prompt shipping
because I had a couple pieces from my
bedroom that are from article and I
ordered them and expected to like never
see them because that's how furniture
works and less than two weeks later some
guy was like hey I'm outside I'm like
hello come on Adam it was fabulous
article is offering our listeners $50
off your first purchase of $100 or more
go to article comm slash toast and the
discount will be automatically applied
at check out
that's article dot-com slash toast to
get $50 off your first purchase of $100
or more
thank you article for being a fabulous
and consistent sponsor of this show
love it oh my gosh when you talk about
article outdoor furniture I think of
Lauren Elizabeth's outdoor situation and
I am just green with envy so if you love
a patio article if you have a patio make
it the happiest place on earth
and get some notify outdoor furniture
from article okay first story is sad
because Jerry Stiller the Seinfeld actor
and comedian has died at the age of 92
Jerry Stiller the beloved comedy legend
who starred in Seinfeld and the King of
Queens has died his son Ben Stiller
announced on Monday Ben Stiller tweeted
early this morning quote I'm sad to say
that my father Jerry Stiller passed away
from natural causes he was a great dad
and grandfather and the most dedicated
husband to an for about 62 years he'll
be greatly missed love you dad up we're
about to get a sneeze chess I'm not sure
sorry um so yes this is a very sad story
but I just have to say like I think that
I mean my husband is probably like Jerry
Stiller's number one fan and when I told
him that he died this morning I
accidentally said Jerry Seinfeld
because Geoghan was in Seinfeld and it
was a yeah fusion at the dinner table um
and now he has time to process and he's
like devastated because Ben has a very
specific type of humor and it's like
that old Jewish man humor and that's
literally Jerry Stiller heavyweights
Seinfeld Zoolander like everything Ben
loves Jerry Stiller just like happens to
be in it so this is a very sad day for a
lot of people but you know what like I
don't think there's a better way to go
out
then at 92 after a very successful
career a great family a great marriage
everyone loves you you know
controversies you know what I think that
we should be celebrating his life yeah I
think that we are and to me he's so
familiar-looking but I know it's not
from Seinfeld or or something like that
or King of Queens if I just looked at
his his IMDB no he is in Hairspray he's
mr. pinky of course oh my god iconic yep
that's how I know him that's his that's
his um that's his big girl for me I mean
he was literally like the
hardest-working man in Hollywood well
into his 80s I feel like if things had
worked out ever
him and Joan Rivers might have been a
cute couple like Jewish old and very
hard-working yeah but a lot of things
would have had to have worked out
differently well no I believe his wife
passed away like a few years ago so they
could have just been there for each
other you know they could have sweet
story a sweet man sweet family
very funny family yeah then is doing
okay he like fell off the face of the
earth like what was the last movie he
did he did that weird one with Kristen
Wiig yeah but I think he he like does
well for himself I I don't think he's
too like concerned I feel like he
enjoyed his life he made so many movies
at one point and now I think he's just
coasted Osten mm-hmm yeah it's like
ideal he was so famous he was like at
the height with like Katherine Heigl
like they were just playing every movie
in there like respective roles like she
was rom-com girl and he was like funny
man then and there really are so many
iconic movies that Ben Stiller did
heavyweights is literally just one of my
favorite movies if you've never seen it
it's like it's an iconic movie but it's
not like the most popular movie in the
world so if you've never seen it it's
very good it's it's excellent Ben and
Jerry Stiller on it or in it yeah I'm
starting to feel like movies that people
loved when they were younger and then
someone watches them when they're older
for the first time it just doesn't hit
like first of all watching in 2020 a
movie that was made in the 90s on your
HD television plasma LED like it's not
it's not so premium and then like you
have to have loved it as a child in
order for you to have affection for it
as an adult is what I'm starting to
learn like and that really was talking
about those movie of the day well that's
true but I don't think that's the case
for every movie I think heavyweights
really holds its own in 2020 I mean
first of all it's yes but it holds its
own for someone who has already loved it
like if some I just curious to see I
disagree well you wouldn't know you're
not in the position of challenge someone
said I'm Carrie yeah someone who's never
seen it watch it let us know what you
think it's so good I mean that movie
could never be made now it's just like
so not PC lunch has been canceled due to
lack of hustle like it could but it's so
perfect like in the moment and as
someone actually maybe that's true cuz
Jackie and I had the experience of
spending many summers at a fat camp and
the movie heavy weights is about a fat
camp so maybe that's why oh and the
first time I saw it was at fat camp so
maybe that's why I have such a but Ben
never went to a fat camp and he like
dies for that movie yeah but he saw it
super young and he would die for that
movie but I feel like a toaster age
thirty who's never seen the movie before
and never went to a fat camp would put
it on and be like this isn't for me like
that's kind of how I feel about the
Sandlot I know a lot of people love it
um but for me I'm just like what these
kids need a bath ya know it's like
there's sand everywhere you know there's
a lot of sand and who loves the Sandlot
I sold once like I think in camp like on
a bus like going onto some trip and I
just didn't understand the whole thing I
just do not [ __ ] with this a lot like
they're just some be like that I know
aren't for me like this and lot not for
me
burpees not for me you know a movie I
feel like is not for you by any stretch
of the imagination angels in the
outfield yes but that's not what I was
thinking
holes okay here's the thing like it's
definitely aesthetically not my thing
but it's a great film it's a great story
based on a very good book therefore I
can appreciate the greatness and so even
though they two could use a shower um I
I like that movie because it's actually
a good movie object and Sigourney
Weaver's in it yeah and then they like
get the solution everyone like makes a
lot of money and I love a happy ending
like that where like kids get a water
slide at the end of the day the best
yeah so that's out on that
rest in peace Jerry Stiller okay this
next story is like the big story of the
weekend there's so many different parts
to it but it is about the beefy vibe
between Allison Roman and chrissy teigen
crazy okay so Allison Roman um is a in
the food community I'm not in the food
community so I was unfamiliar with her
work but but if you are in the food
community she's very well-respected
right um
so she had some choice words about
chrissy teigen trajectory in the food
world she said to the new consumer she
said quote what Chrissy Teigen has done
is so crazy to me
she had a successful cookbook and then
it was like boom line at Target boom now
she has an Instagram page that has over
a million followers where it's just like
people running a content farm for her
that horrifies me and it's not something
that I ever want to do I don't aspire to
that she did note however that Chrissy
it's approach is probably earning her
tons of income she also said but like
who's laughing now because she's making
a [ __ ] ton of money the food columnist
also took a swing at organizing
consultant Marie Kondo for being a
hypocrite she said quote the idea that
when Marie Kondo decided to capitalize
on her fame and make stuff that you can
buy that is completely antithetical to
everything she's ever taught you I'm
like damn [ __ ] you [ __ ] just sold
out immediately someone's like you
should make stuff and she's like okay
slap my name on it I don't give a [ __ ]
so her comments drew some backlash
online but she didn't back down
she said when women bully other women
for being honest about money and how
much they do or do not make well that's
amore just wishing I had someone to hold
my hand during baby's first inter life
internet backlash she tweeted on Friday
so Chrissy Teigen saw Allison Herman's
remarks took to her Twitter about how
disappointed she was because she's been
a fan of her for so long
um let me pull up Chrissy's tweets via
the honestly Chrissy's tweets for just
like what you said about like my product
line and my content farm it's exact
opposite it's me and one other person
she's like I worked tirelessly on this
product line she was really like not
that I thought she was playing the
victim at all but she was really like
making me feel bad for her yeah she said
this is a huge bummer and hit me hard I
have made her recipes for years now
bought the cookbooks supported her on
social and praised her in interviews I
even signed on to executive produced the
very show she talks about doing in this
article I started cravings because I
wanted something for myself I wanted
something John didn't buy I wanted
something to do that calmed me made me
happy and made others happy too cravings
isn't a machine or a farmed content it's
me and two other women she said I
genuinely loved everything about Alison
was jealous she got to have a book with
food on the cover instead of a face I've
made countless New York Times recipes
she's created
sing along the way she wrote of oh so I
guess I'll sing Roman is a New York
Times food columnist got it I mean to me
this is like the definition of like
loser a crime but if I have to get into
it it's like I just don't understand
like the point that Allison made in this
article was so brilliant that she needed
to like stand down and like stand her
ground like what are you doing like what
do you care so much about other people
it sounds like you're jealous you don't
have a product line and I don't know I
just thought this was really losery and
then like her responses were even more
looser because she had stood her ground
firmly until chrissy teigen responded
then chrissy responded and Allison wrote
a bunch of tweets that were so lame like
just apologizing and like groveling
immediately and then people were
tweeting at Christie it's like she's
groveling but I just want you to know
like in the interview she literally
mouthed I hate her about Chrissy Teigen
so Chrissy responded to that person mean
like good to know she never responded to
Allison it's like to me this is the
worst way to handle a controversy like
either stand your ground or don't or
she's just like she's yeah anything
about her but like now I think she's a
weenie yeah here's the thing I think
Chrissy Hickey needn't handled this in
the best possible way to handle the
controversy even though she was like not
in the wrong whatsoever so she could
only like go up from here but I feel
like she really used this as a great
opportunity to show people why she's so
passionate about what they do and now I
like want to go to cravings Instagram
page and like buy some of her [ __ ] at
Target and support her and when it comes
to Alison Roman like she's entitled to
her opinion and I'm not in this world so
I don't have an opinion on what she said
but like if you're gonna be a [ __ ] go
[ __ ] all the way like go like don't be
a [ __ ] and then like and like just sit
by what you said if that's what you had
said right like I think it was and
that's clearly how you feel about
product lines which seems like a fair
thing to feel if you are in this
industry so stand by it but like to like
backpedal and and it's just like got
really sad and then Chrissy to them I
just totally totally won I thought it
was weird I've heard of like use this
interview as like a platform to take
down other women in the industry like if
that's your thing okay fine
but then just a backpedal so hard like
makes me lose all respect for you like
if I don't agree with what you're saying
but like you are standing firm in your
opinion so you know what I respect
someone was an opinion and like stands
around but just to like wave
all over the place especially when you
started this like it's just looser I'm
sorry yeah this was her apology she said
hi a chrissy teigen I sent an email but
also wanted to say here that I'm
genuinely sorry I caused you pain with
what I said I shouldn't have used you
slasher business or Marie's as an
example to show what I wanted for my own
career
it was flippant careless and I'm sorry
so lame like I just can't
[Laughter]
yeah um yeah but I'm happy for chrissy
teigen because she really came out on
top and i think people will be buying
her cookbook and people are obsessed she
is like a crazy like fanbase when it
comes to food and that you can't get her
products they sell out our target and
she's doing well and i understood what
she meant she was like I just want
something that was like mine everyone
thinks I'm like John's wife like I
totally got that and I like respected
the backstory of cravings cuz I never
really understood how she went from like
model to chef and like now I get it
yes speaking of product lines um
something happened to me when I was at
this store on essentials run recently
because I was looking at some of the
products you know how they sell like um
knives and you know kitchen tools at the
supermarket so I saw there was an onion
chopper and I was actually like oh
interested because I always cry when I
chop my onions now and then I saw it was
from Alex McCord's product line Alex
McCord as in real houses and I almost
bought it but I didn't tweet but I might
now she's a psychologist who lives in
Australia now she has an onion chopping
product line and I saw it at my local
grocery store which doesn't even have
like a wide array of section so she got
shelf space and it's premium shelf space
even though it's really high up and I
can't reach it on what they expect you
to do actually I just went to your
grocery store and I was looking for a
can opener and it was all it was above
the freezer right like aniline well what
they do is like they have all the aisles
of groceries and I guess this makes
sense in New York City and then above
everything all the shelves there runs a
row of things that are pretty much like
kitchen appliances on every aisle they
have this really high top row of
different kitchen appliances that you
would never know about unless you're
like searching for an onion chopper um I
actually bought a paring knife
up there the other day and I was jumping
god forbid someone [ __ ] helps I don't
know why you didn't get the onion
chopper sounds I used to have a little
chop chopper that he would use for
garlic and onions and it was so fabulous
I don't know where it went
was it okay you know maybe when I go
back I'll get it like to support you no
it's about one of our own yeah um the
McCord family and I will full review
yeah I'll report back maybe I can
expense it if it's like a business
inquiry you know I'll allow it
okay cool um anyways I just remembered
that and in general I'm just like so
here for product lines you know of
course like I love a celebrity product
line I don't know why this woman would
choose not to have a product line I mean
it seems silly yeah if someone comes to
you like with a product line find the
product that you've always wanted out
there and make it fabulous I get that
they're definitely situations where
people just slap their names I'm like a
shitty Bowl and sell it at Target I get
that but like for her to just assume it
like every woman does that like I am
sure Chrissy Teigen make sure her knives
are [ __ ] stellar I am sure Marie
Kondo make sure her lucite boxes are the
most efficient and storage holding
[ __ ] out there you know what I mean
like for her just to assume that
everyone says shitty of a business owner
as she is like that's just not cool yeah
I will say though the point that she
made about Marie Kondo like she makes
you get rid of all your stuff and now
she's making you buy stuff um I see
where she's coming from yeah I did see
the whole antithetical vibe yes I
totally agree so anyways that's the
major drama that happened this weekend
once again Chrissy Teigen came out on
top um and that's what you missed on
Glee
okay you ready for our next story no
okay do you want to ask me why sure if
you want to open up and share yeah I
just have something to say today's
episode is brought to you by cross rope
these days we're all looking for ways to
stay fit while we're spending more time
at home cardio machines aren't exactly
motivating and the cost of home gym
equipment can add up fast we've found a
cool different way to get a great
workout for a fraction of the cost
it's called cross rope the sleek
weighted jump rope system that makes
working out at home fun thanks to cross
her up the most efficient cardio workout
just got even better weighted ropes
combined high intensity cardio with full
body strength training
your heart rate up while working your
core back shoulders arms glutes and more
it's no fluff just a fun effective
workout that anyone can do cross rope is
reinventing the home workout experience
their ropes get better feedback which
makes it easier for beginners to get
started and learn they have durable
steel ropes
ergonomic handles and patented fast clip
system for swapping rope weights fast
you can get free anytime access to quick
workouts and fun challenges with the
cross rope app now you can pursue your
fitness goals wherever you are even at
home it's easy to get started with the
cross syrup just order your ropes
download the app and enjoy the results
choose between their get lean or get
strong sets depending on your fitness
goals or get their best value for both
sets with the Get Fit bundle track your
workouts and see a map of your progress
on the free cross rope app cross rope is
so sure you'll love the whole experience
they even offer a 60-day risk free
guarantee I love an app I love something
that's small and compact like I live in
New York I don't even have space for
like um myself let alone like a home gym
so just being able to like throw
something in my Ottoman my Ottoman opens
up and just like hiding it when a
company comes over like that's the best
part of this product for me and I think
that everyone should look into anything
it's a really fabulous brand so if
you're ready for a new cardio and a
full-body home workout visit cross rope
comm slash toast
that's ER OSS ro PE comm slash toast get
up to $40 off cross r up sets plus free
shipping when you check out today at
cross rope comm slash toast that CRO SS
ro PE comm slash toast
thank you cross rope for sponsoring this
episode okay I'm getting so excited for
this ad because I got my cross ropes a
few weeks ago and I've been implementing
them when I do my at-home virtual
training sessions and they're like
obviously just jump ropes they're so
small but like now I'm really building
up my home gym because I have these like
weighted jump ropes and if you haven't
jumped roped in a while like it is a
[ __ ] hard workout and this is just
like the perfect at-home accessory to
have if you want to be working out at
home because it's so tiny like you don't
have to make so much space for it and
it's very effective workout so I highly
recommend okay so sorry to have
interrupted you that was very rude Diplo
confirms he welcomed a baby with
model Javon King Diplo has confirmed
that he is a father of three the 41 year
old DJ posted a Mother's Day tribute to
quote the three strongest mothers in the
world and included a picture of the
model Javon King holding their newborn
he also posted a photo of his ex
Katherine Lockhart with their two sons
as well as an old snapshot of his own
mother quote he said in a series of
images I'm still a work in progress but
you have given three perfect beautiful
you have given three perfect beautiful
boys I love you all till the moon and
back Wow yeah I think the most like
underrated in fact about Diplo up until
now was that he had two kids I mean
there one really handsome um and now I
guess he has a third he's so like
thirsty in a way like on social media
but he also was very private about his
private life
yeah and they think that's the best way
to be you know cuz he's he gives us so
much of him but then he keeps some stuff
for himself
um and he shares when he's ready to and
I think this is so beautiful I'm so
happy for mommy and daddy and baby yeah
but there's like a subgroup of people
who are absolutely head-over-heels
obsessed in love with Diplo and I just
feel like this really broke them today
like I want to you know speak directly
to those people our friend Nicole
Brookman is just absolutely thinks that
she is gonna marry Diplo one day and
there's so many people that feel that
way in the rave community so I just want
you guys to know we see you we are here
for you and I'm sorry that this woman is
not you yeah I agree I think I need to
send a wellness check text message to
her today and just like make sure
everything's okay and how she took those
no I'm sure that she's not but we just
have to be there for her you know she'll
get through this yeah and we're here for
all the other Diplo tip low stirs who
really are feeling down today because
I'm not one of them like obviously I
love Diplo but some people like actually
like want to like eat his butt like they
love him so much
no I actually I'm not one of those
people but I completely understand those
people like I I see what you see and I
feel what you feel and I get it and
we're here for you um but in the
meantime we're also gonna be happy for
diplomas Arie yes of course cuz you know
he's like such an I I mean I've only met
him once but he was so nice and like I
just feel like everyone around town like
people just love and respect him yeah he
is so well respected I was
going through my camera roll and I saw
that I had screen shot at a post of his
he's coming out with an album at the end
of May and all country album called
snake oil and I would have forgotten
that but I was just looking at some old
pics probably going through pictures for
my presets um and so that's just an
exciting factoid that I find exciting
very exciting happy for Diplo happy
Mother's Day to Diplo and his new
girlfriend or whatever but yeah he
didn't say anything about them being
together but who knows
okay the sex story um I have chosen
because it's exciting and because I'm
just an ugly Betty Stan these days
America Ferrera and husband Ryan Pierce
Williams welcomed a second child
Jacki you do not need to explain
yourself forever choosing an America
Ferrera story like she's iconic in so
many ways and so you don't need to
explain yourself I know I'm just
wondering if I would have chosen this
story if I wasn't in the middle of an
ugly Betty pinch like I might have not
had the appreciation at the forefront of
my mind for America Ferrera and that
would have been a crime I mean everyone
America fell in love with America
Ferrera when she like snatched our
hearts in Sisterhood of the Traveling
Pants but like we were so on to her
before that like I really feel like I
could get out yes she was seasick way
ahead like she was a real role model for
me like in a lot of ways you know she
really was and the more I watch out Li
Betty like the more that Betty Suarez is
just the most precious gem of the human
being and the most precious protagonists
like she's so she's a moral compass of
New York City in this show and like I
need publications Oh big-time and I love
her so much I love the show I just have
such an appreciation for and she's so
cute and sweet and like when she'll be
in a bed a bit like Hilda gives her
lollipop and like you know she's about
to smile like it's so cute I'm obsessed
with her the scenes at their house in
Queens are like so precious like I feel
like if anyone watches that they like
immediately like start missing their
family and like their the house they
grew up and it's so precious and the dad
is so cute no and like everyone from
like need and from mode convenes at the
Suarez house like when Claire Meade has
to go to their house um because she's
gonna turn herself in to the police like
it's just it's it's amazing like I'm
truly obsessed when
Marcus at her house Amanda like oh my
god and then Betty sad makes Amanda flan
because like she stress eats and like
she's just obsessed with the flan I just
I can't you guys if you've never watched
Ugly Betty now's your time the character
who plays Betty's dad is like the go-to
villain on ABC like he is oh yeah
Alejandro and Desperate Housewives he's
always playing a villain and to be such
a dynamic actor because he is now like
this the heart and soul of Queens like
he's just so cute and so everything and
he's really just she could do both you
know ya know but he's really actually in
the show he he's like obviously like the
lovable he's not a bad guy at all but
like he's not very responsible you know
he's always just trying to like put off
like important things and like I said
like his health yes and the girls have
to like take care of him and it's like
just take your heart pills you know
we're not asking a lot no we're not
asking a lot okay back to America fair
she had plenty to celebrate this
Mother's Day on Sunday the actress
announced the arrival of her second
child with husband Ryan Pierce Williams
daughter Lucia Marisol
Lucia Marisol Williams her I've done may
4th to give me my Mother's Day hugs and
kisses herself she wrote on Instagram
mama daddy and big brother are over the
moon to welcome her bright light to our
family that is so cute so happy for
Betty so happy Justin's gonna have a
cousin this is just fabulous oh my god
so now I'm a two favorite characters I'm
I'm almost at the end of season 1 are
Justin Suarez and Claire Meade and when
the two of them happen to be in the same
scene it's movie magic magic magic um
this has been really enjoyable watching
Ugly Betty like I've now I'm one of
those people who's just like watches TV
all day during the queue actually that
was over the weekend I wonder I don't
think I'll do it during the weekdays not
until like 5 o'clock that's when I start
that's what I try and do too I try and
stay off the TV until like almost
dinnertime
yeah and dinner times just getting
earlier and earlier yeah it's just close
as I could get like eating a 5:30 now
and also a second dinner at 10:00 yeah
I've been doing um and since I'm
actually really trying to like get in
shape now I've been using an app to
the log of what I'm eating so they can
tell me like what I'm eating wrong and
whatnot um and just like trying to say
if I eat at four o'clock a meal I don't
know is that lunch or dinner or
breakfast like I I can't categorize them
anymore everything's just a snack yeah I
feel the pressure to categorize and
label all my meals is just it's an
attack on humanity and that's why I
don't do it and you know what meals are
actually a social construct so I just
I'm not gonna be participating anymore
I completely agree it's such a social
construct I love referred to things as
social constructs know cuz when you
think about it like someone has
constructed this for society but it's
not real ya know meals are the
definition of social construct like what
and who decides that what a meal versus
snack is
yeah and that there needs to be three
each day why not five oh my god my Mac
will sleep soon unless plugged into a
power outlet can you pause like can you
talk to everyone but your promote your
Jackie Oh Flo I'm just ready to get my
charger oh okay yeah because this next
story is brought to you by Jackie Oh Flo
my presets that are just gonna change
your Instagram feed and make them so fun
and vibrant and like everything of the
sort so if you are interested in getting
those things on your Instagram flow or
just like brightening up pictures if you
know you had like a cloudy day and the
pictures weren't great like a Jackie O
flow preset will change that right up my
new pastel pack is out now head to
Jackie O flow comm to get it on and pop
in there really easy to download but if
you've never used presets before and
they can be very daunting so I'm just in
the middle of an ad from one of our
sponsors I have a tutorial on my youtube
page of how to download them it makes it
really easy and sort of explains what
presets do and why you should even use
them in the first place so we have
nothing but time the cube get familiar
with presets head to Jackie O flow calm
okay I got my charger sorry that was
such a crazy rush Wow okay are you ready
for a fifth and final story yes ma'am
julianne hough surprises her mom Maryann
with the house for Mother's Day it's
quote her time to receive okay I love
stir I know you're iffy on Julianne
Hough but I love stories that's what I
was buying their parents houses I mean I
was literally about to like roll my eyes
to the back of my head if it was another
Brooks
Aitch story and like they're crumbling
marriage which is like all definitely
some sort of PR vibe so I'm glad it's
not and I agree like in the One
Direction documentary I really like Zayn
but when he bought his mom a house and
like the way she just cried like I will
always have respect for Zayn because of
that I completely agree in honor of all
the love and support her mother Marianne
has given her and her siblings over the
years julianne hough decided to surprise
her with the ultimate gift a new home
quote this is yours mom the actress and
dancer says in a sweet video documenting
the surprise while keeping her mother a
big hug Thank You Marianne replies as
the pair continued to wrap their arms
around each other and Happiness um I saw
this on Julian House Instagram and the
house is literally the cutest most
perfect like picturesque looking house
I'd ever seen and I'm so jealous
that's so sweet that is like everything
I feel like to be able to pay your
parents back like I remember this is
such a weird reference but when Snooki
did an interview after Jersey Shore and
some was like what's been the best thing
that happened to you
she's like it's the financial security
like being able to pay my parents back
all the money like they spent on me like
it's the best feeling in the world and I
just feel like that is so special that
is so special um and I just I like this
story and I said huh you know I'm
curious about her finances like I'm I'm
definitely interested okay she works
really hard like she's always on a
million different shows she's on she was
on Dancing with the Stars but not
anymore
um and also she's of like a big
influencer you know I feel like if you
were a brand like Julianne Hough is
definitely a very good brand ambassador
I think she makes a lot of brand money I
think she's always working doing her
shows like world of dance and all that
stuff she does her own like Tony Robbins
style move thing right so now she's
doing less of like the Dancing with the
Stars and more of the Tony Robbins thing
and I'm just interested that's it I
think she does really well like better
than you would expect for um for her and
she was in movies that like every movie
she was in which I loved was a major
flop like that Footloose reboot was
fabulous and it got no love justice for
miles teller justice for miles teller oh
my god he was so so great in that movie
I loved everything about the footless
Footloose free boot but then she was
also in like Rock of Ages and that was
tough yeah she I just feel like she
takes roles where she can sing and dance
and more often than not those types of
movies like 1 in 10 are fabulous you
know yeah I mean maybe for you but like
for me they have to be really bad for me
not to like them like Rock of Ages she
was awesome in safe house which is just
such a beautiful movie um justice for
that movie
yeah except for the end where it like
got a little dark um okay should we dive
into TV recap oh yeah go for it um what
did you watch over the weekend I watched
Hollywood and I watched dead to me
season 2 and I'm um in the middle well
not in the middle in the beginning of
the new season of working moms which is
like my favorite show I've been waiting
for season 4 it's just such like a light
and happy show and it's nothing crazy
and it just like always brings me joy
it's funny it makes me never want to be
a mom but it's just like so light and
fun and I can't wait to watch it
even though I did not hear great things
about season 4 um put our TV recap
segment I'm so sorry I got ahead of
myself it's brought to you by fiber
because let's talk about finding
freelance talent for your business or
project sometimes a business needs to
quickly pivot in order to meet a goal or
maybe an unexpected obstacle occurs
making it impossible to meet your
deadline with the size of your current
team where do you go to find on-demand
talent how much will it cost how can you
be certain they'll deliver finding the
right freelancer can be time-consuming
frustrating and expensive fibers
platforming helps keep business moving
with the network of trusted freelance
talent whether you're launching your
first business scaling your current
business or in need of extra support to
complete a project Fiverr is here to
help you evolve adapt and grow fiber
connects businesses with freelancers who
offer hundreds of digital services
including graphic design copywriting web
programming film editing and more you
can find what you're looking for
instantly where you search by service
deadline price reviews and more you'll
know exactly what you're paying for
upfront because there's no negotiation
needed and they have 24/7 customer
service you can find quality talent
talent that you can count on their
sellers have worked with some of the
most influential brands in the world so
finally talent for your project has
never been easier
you can review seller ratings by your
feedback and select the right freelancer
based on your budget
check out fiber comm today and receive
10% off your first order by using our
code toast it's so easy you can find all
the digital services you need in one
place at fib er are.com code toast
again that's fibre with two hours at the
end fiber comm / toast love it sign on
get some great help okay
TV recap so did you watch Hollywood or
dead to me season two no because I'm
still thoroughly enjoying Ugly Betty and
I'm gonna ride this wave until I'm
looking for something new and then I'll
have so much exciting stuff to watch so
I know it's really annoying and I don't
want spoilers but I could turn my I was
just gonna say trimmed off a few things
to say okay okay I watched Hollywood me
and Ben absolutely loved it I thought
the fact that it was a miniseries was
perfect timing and I feel like it was
too long or too short the casting was
great the glamour of Hollywood I could
die for right after it was over I like
rushed to Google because I was so
confused about who was real and at first
I didn't realize that it was based on
any real people until they changed that
guy Roy's name to rock and I realized it
was Rock Hudson who was an actor who was
in the closet and then at the end of
this series like him and his boyfriend
were on the red carpet and I was like I
don't think that ever happened
um and then I went back and read this
whole People magazine article comparing
and contrasting what was real what was
not
Rock Hudson never came out with his
boyfriend nobody really knew he was gay
until the end of his life where he was
diagnosed with AIDS and then that's how
people found out but up until then
nobody knew that he was gay
so that was the only person whose name I
recognized a lot of the other characters
were based on other people like the
Hollywood agent was a real guy Jim
Parsons was phenomenal like he was
probably the best actor in my opinion
like he did the most with his role I
didn't realize that Jack was the guy
river from the politician and his wife
who was pregnant but it ended up being
spoiler alert the other kids babies that
is jet Apatow his daughter
Maude Apatow she looked so different the
cast was like really blowing my mind
when I went on IMDB I did so much
research afterwards I
I really liked it I thought it was an
amazing story I mean that's obviously
like not how diversity happened in
Hollywood diversity is still a huge
problem in Hollywood but I liked this
like idealistic utopia where just like
overnight you know people became
excessive accepted whether you were gay
or you were black obviously that's not
how it happened because people still to
this day like struggle to get cast and
Hollywood is very much like
overwhelmingly white but I loved like
living in the Utopia when that girl won
the Oscar at the end I mean it was just
I had chills ever and then the writer
won and everyone except for Jack Jack
was like one of my least favorite
characters he was being so annoying and
dumb but after my research so the the
entire series is based on a book written
by the gas station owner Ernie and he
was my favorite character like when he
ended up with that lady from the studio
it was just it was really perfect I feel
like the series just tied itself up at
the end everyone like found someone it
was a really happy ending which is not
how it works in Hollywood but I
appreciated the the happy ending because
I hate watching stuff and that gives me
pits you know like I hate watching
things where like everything goes wrong
I just really enjoyed all of it and I'm
gonna talk about dead to be Season 2
because I don't think that Jackie
watched it it was fire like that final
scene I was dying the whole show I was
like oh my god I don't want them to get
caught like I get that christina
applegate is a murderer because it
wasn't self-defense and she like
randomly just killed someone which makes
her like a cold-blooded murderer but I
just feel like she's a good person and
she was like trying to do the right
thing and like her friendship with Judy
I mean the kid found the letter at the
end it never occurred to me that the
kids don't know that Judy was the one
that killed their dad so when they found
that letter I was like [ __ ] and the kid
Charlie was bothering me the whole
season he was like doing things he
wasn't spose to do anyone taking things
he wasn't supposed to take and reading
things he wasn't supposed to read it's
just like go to school he was just being
so insane and I'm like just be a kid get
out of your mom's ass like go make out
with a girl he was just he was being bad
but it was a fabulous season when james
marsden showed up I was like no [ __ ]
way and then I liked that he was still
in the show but he just played his
identical twin and I loved him and I
really want him and christina applegate
to be together but um they're obviously
not going to be because she murdered his
brother so I just don't think that's how
things work out
but his mom was so sweet in that house
oh my god I like want to move to
Laguna it was so fabulous and then when
Christine appliquéd started having like
financial problems it was just like pit
pit pit and then when james marsden was
in the freezer for the first few
episodes of my girls get him out I just
loved the friendship between Christine
and Judy I don't know what's gonna
happen next season because not only are
we dealing with the fact that james
marsden drunk drove drunk drove and
almost murdered judy and christina
applegate we're also are dealing with
the fact that the son now found the
letter that christina applegate wrote to
Judy saying I forgive you for killing my
husband so the kids are about to find
out find out that the woman living in
their guesthouse for the last two years
or whatever has actually been the woman
who murdered their dad and there's just
a lot to unpack so I'm very excited it
is such a good show like the scenery
that everything Christina Applegate is
fabulous Linda Karlen these fabulous
James Marsden is fabulous it's really
good so that's my recap I'm officially
out of breath and I'm gonna bring it
back to Jackie
are we back are we back in business
yes I reek up dead to me season two and
Hollywood so you are free oh wow okay
and I'll we'll go through it again when
I watch them but it probably won't be
for it like a few days yeah so I just
know a lot of people watch it over the
weekend and I didn't want that no good
I'm glad and you had all this stuff at
the tip of your tongue like we could
never have done this I guess this is a
pro of being on zoom like we could have
never done this in the studio because
I'm sitting right there but you know we
gotta make the most of the platform so
I'm so glad that you were able to UM to
spoil it spoiler-free
cool um what else did I watch this
weekend I think really I don't think my
input left Hulu um for Buble Betty so
good so good um that's all for me that's
all family to her she said that it's all
the cheer oh but she did want me to tell
everyone that I'm on Nicklaus podcast
today and it's actually really funny we
did an advice segment and everyone who
called in was pretty much a toaster
which was just made me look so cool in
front of Nick so thank you guys all the
people who called in like appreciate
love you um and so check it out it's on
iTunes it was really funny it's a long
episode so if you need something to
watch it's like over an hour Oh amazing
also I did speak to her
as well and she was busy putting my
presets on every new photo and she said
definitely had to Jackie afloat comm for
the new pastel pack and make sure to tag
me in hashtag Jackie O flow when you use
them so I can see them and get so
excited also we are doing a patreon
episode that is d'art toast verse
specific for patreon members so head
over to patron compost if you would like
us to answer your specific question it's
a bit of a smaller community than here
in the morning tote so I think we can
get a little bit more personal as we
always do on patreon and if you are
looking for new content head over to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast
because we have five episodes coming at
you this month if you've never been a
patron before you have like literally
over 100 episodes waiting for you if you
sign up today at patreon.com slash
almost 200 that's insane have you been
doing the head around now for we've been
doing patreon for like two years now
yeah that's five episodes a month twelve
months of two years that's insane that's
so much content for you um so chit chit
chit chat check it out thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning to a
similarly a morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube that are
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up please we're also available as
a podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
set Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio
iHeartRadio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast find us
the morning toast and please leave a
five star view about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are I made a major
mistake and going to look at our most
recent podcast reviews and they are
absolutely brutal and they made ya so
sad so well you know that makes sense
cuz like you know everyone just like who
hates us wants to let us know but if you
do have something nice to say now would
be a time to boost morale we appreciate
it get those five star reviews up so
please check that out thank you guys so
much we will see you tomorrow bye